today on the Matt Walsh show the latest
me two allegations against Fox including
this time Tucker Carlson and Sean
Hannity are perhaps the most frivolous
harassment claims we've heard yet we'll
talk about that also five headlines
including George Stephanopoulos his wife
says that she would watch porn with her
adolescent daughter she says it'll be a
learning experience for them and so she
would be willing to do that and in our
daily cancellation we discussed the
unnamed woman speaking of pornography
who got naked for the cops at a Portland
protest and showed off her genitals to
the police officers something tells me
that you know although this woman is
being celebrated as a hero by the media
she would not be received in quite so
positive a light if this was a naked
dude showing off for women so we'll talk
about the double standard there that and
much more on the way today on the Matt
Walsh show now we begin here I you know
and I must admit I'm not a huge fan of
cable news myself it's not how I choose
to get my information I generally find
that cable news hosts tend to be
uninteresting and the insights they
offer such as they are the talking
points they offer are usually
superficial and redundant one of the
very few exceptions in my opinion to
that rule is Tucker Carlson who actually
uses his platform to say things that are
necessary and important and he engages
with issues and engages in a way that
others won't even other conservatives
well especially other conservatives with
comparable platforms won't and this has
made Tucker the highest-rated host on
cable news the most relevant voice in
media by far the most talked about voice
in media it's also made him a target a
prime target and it's why even though he
has the highest rated rated show on
cable news a lot of advertisers have
fled because the left is focused
intently on scaring away his sponsors to
silence him
last week the media ran wild with a
story about inappropriate stuff one of
Tucker Carlson's staff members posted
anonymously on a message board
this was supposed to be a huge scandal
for Tucker Carlson for some reason that
one of his staff members was posting
edgy content on a message board
anonymously because I guess what Tucker
is supposed to be monitoring the
activity even anonymous activity of all
the people that work for him because
that's a normal thing that that I guess
all all media personalities do then last
night Tucker reveal that the New York
Times was planning to Docs him and
expose his family to harm again not for
the first time here he is addressing
that watch last week the New York Times
began working on a story about where my
family and I live as a matter of
journalism there is no conceivable
justification for a story like that the
paper is not alleging we've done
anything wrong and we haven't you pay
our taxes we like our neighbors we've
never had a dispute with anyone so why
is the New York Times doing a story on
the location of my family's house well
you know why to hurt us to injure my
wife and kids so that I will shut up and
stop disagreeing with them they believe
in force we've learned that two years
ago a left-wing journalist publicized
our home address in Washington a group
of screaming and Tifa lunatics showed up
while I was at work they vandalized her
home they threatened my wife she called
9-1-1 while hiding in a closet a few
weeks later they showed up again at our
house for the next year they sent
letters to our home threatening to kill
us we tried to ignore it it felt
cowardly to sell our home and leave we'd
raised our kids there in the
neighborhood and we loved it but in the
end that's what we did we have four
children it just wasn't worth it but the
New York Times followed us the paper is
assigned a political activist called
Marie carpenter to write a story about
where we are now they've hired a
photographer called Tristan spin ski to
take pictures their story about where we
live is slated to run in the paper this
week editors there know exactly what
will happen to my family when it does
run I called them today and I told them
but they didn't care they hate my
politics they want this show off the air
if one of my children gets hurt because
of a story they wrote they won't
consider it collateral damage they know
it's the whole point of the exercise
inflict pain on our family to terrorize
us to control what we say that's the
kind of people they are now the times
for the record says they aren't planning
to run with any piece like that so it's
a it's a he said they said sort of
situation and I can tell you that I
don't believe the New York Times for a
second it's it's not like they don't
have a track record of doing this kind
of thing I have no trouble believing
what tucker carlson saying here it's
much harder to believe that tucker would
just invent this out of whole cloth and
name names something he came up with on
his own a fiction story it's harder to
believe that that it is to believe that
the New York Times got called out and is
now lying to cover their own asses and
then so that's you know two things we
remember this is all within you know a
week or two then yesterday also we have
the big breaking news which the rest of
media is amplifying with trumpet blasts
of celebration that two women are filing
harassment suits against a whole bunch
of Fox News employees and personalities
including Tucker Carlson and others as
per usual when people on the rights are
accused these allegations are being
taken at face value because of course
we're back to believe all women right
we're back to that again we took a break
with Joe Biden now we're back now we're
but now we're believing women again you
know we we there was a couple months
there when weren't supposed to believe
women anymore but now yeah we can
believe them again and but if and of
course these allegations then because
believe all women these allegations are
being taken at face value as fact with
very little skepticism but let's take a
look at the actual allegations you tell
me if these seem credible to you you be
the judge here okay I'm gonna read now
from the AP report this is what it says
Fox News Channel star sean hannity
tucker carlson and howard kurtz were
accused of sexual harassment by a
frequent on-air guest in a lawsuit filed
Monday that the network called frivolous
and untrue in the same case a former Fox
employee said she was harassed and raped
by news anchor Edie Henry who was fired
July 1st shortly after the network
became aware of the accusations Henry's
lawyer Catherine
fodeez said monday that our client's
accuser Jennifer Eckhart initiated and
encouraged a sexual relationship Hannity
and Carlson represent two-thirds of
Fox's lucrative primetime lineup while
Kurtz hosts the weekend media buzz show
none of the men have been mentioned
before in any misconduct allegations of
Fox until the charges were made by Cathy
are you I think is how you pronounce a
our EU the lawsuit filed in New York
describes our use discomfort with a
March 28th 2018 incident on the set of
Hannity show where the host allegedly
put a hundred dollars on a desk and
challenged the men on his staff to take
her out on a date she said she was a
guest on Carlson's show in December 2018
and that after it was over he told her
he was staying in a hotel room in New
York that that night without his wife
and children in 2019 she said Kurt's
invite her to his hotel room to discuss
her hope of getting a full-time job at
Fox when she instead invited him to
dinner with her and a friend he declined
she said in the cases of Carlson Kurtz
are you believed the men were making
sexual advances the lawsuit said are you
said she was also propositioned by Giano
Caldwell a Fox contributor based on an
outside law firms investigation Fox had
have found all of our use claims
patently false frivolous and utterly
devoid of any merit Fox that it would
defend itself vigorously and then are
you also said she got lewd messages from
Edie Henry and then we have also the
accusations against Edie Henry from this
is from Jennifer Eckhart she said she
was 24 at the time she said that 49 year
old Henry restrained her with metal
handcuffs took nude pictures of her and
raped her in a hotel room she said that
she had asked Eckhart 2r that he had
asked that car to be his sex slave and
quote little [ __ ] and punished her when
she did not comply with these demands
okay so there you go there's all there's
all the information first we have Cathy
ru who by the way was not an employee of
Fox at the time of these alleged
incidents who says let's let's go
through these one at a time she says
it's Sean Hannity put a hundred dollars
on a table and offered to pay any man in
the studio to take her out now this
even if it happened isn't sexual
harassment it makes no sense at all why
would Hannity he was gonna pay someone
to take her on a date what is what does
that even mean what's what's the context
here unless there is a context that that
and this was a joke that would make
sense in the context that we're not
being told about now that seems
plausible I guess the idea that Hannity
did it randomly for no reason with no
context just out of nowhere here's 100
bucks someone take this lady on a date
it's just not plausible but either way
whether it happened or not whether
there's context or not it's not
harassment it's a weird joke an absolute
worst then she says Kurtz asked her to
come to his hotel room to talk about
getting a job she says let's go to
dinner and he said no at the end
according to her you know again not
harassment harassment would be if the
propositions continued and they were
unwelcomed of inviting a woman to your
hotel room when she's not your coworker
may not be appropriate it may not be
morally right especially if Kurtz is
married I don't know if he is or not but
it's not harassment and to the charge
against Tucker I mean this is really
just one of the most frivolous sexual
harassment claims I've ever heard in my
life and the people that are amplifying
these claims they know that they know it
and they know that if you actually click
on the headline in the link and you read
what the claim is you're going to
immediately say this is ridiculous
so they know that but but the the goal
here is just to have Tucker and Hannity
labeled as sexual harasser so they all
they want because as it says in the AP
article there have been plenty of other
claims made against Fox News people as
we know Hannity and Tucker have never
been mentioned by anybody before and I
think that is much to this chagrin of
the left and their competitors in the
media who would love it if these guys
were also mentioned and here we go
finally they get it the fact that it's
frivolous doesn't matter because now all
they can do all they care
about is that they can label these guys
as sexual harassers and they could they
could put that asterisks next to their
name for the rest of their lives but
what if she says she says um that he
said to her I'll be alone in the city
tonight the end that's it that's all
that happened according to her even if
her account is completely accurate which
we have no reason to believe that it is
this isn't harassment saying I'm gonna
be alone tonight in the city is sexual
harassment
she chose to interpret it as a sexual
proposition which even if it was again
we have no reason to think it was and we
have no reason to think any of this even
happened but even if it was even if it
happened and even if she interpreted
correctly that's not harassment I can
easily imagine a non-sexual way and
reason why something like that would be
said just for example you know someone
could say how they're gonna be they're
gonna be alone tonight they have a hotel
room to themselves and they're just
happy to get a break that's that's
that's a that's a sentiment people that
would have traveled and have spent a
night alone in hotel room when they've
got kids you know happy for the break
maybe they can relate to that sentiment
so can easily interpret it that way
but this is how she chose to hear it if
it again if it happened at all this is
how she chose to hear
she also says we should note that she
suffered punitive damages for turning
down this alleged implied potential this
is an alleged implied potential sexual
proposition and for turning down this
alleged implied potential sexual sexual
proposition she says that she was
punished because she was only asked to
appear on Tucker's show three times
after that oh the horror the horror you
know I've only been asked to appear in
Tucker's show once I guess he sexually
harassed me to I don't know I apparently
in fact I've been on cable news shows
frequently for for a period and then
suddenly I'm not invited on again it's
pretty common it happens to a lot of
people it could be just that they have
other guests they're bringing on they
just haven't thought about it it could
be that they didn't find me that
interesting it could be that maybe I
said something on
they didn't like I could be that the
news cycle is turned in our direction
where they figure I don't have as much
to offer I mean it could be any of those
explanations or yes maybe it could be
sexual harassment I mean I'm being
punished in some way yeah let's go with
that last explanation it certainly is
the most flattering to me right that's I
would prefer for for that to be the
reason it's better than thinking that I
wasn't invited on because I'm not
interesting that that would be that
would that would really hurt my
self-esteem so those are the claims
against Tucker Hannity and Kurtz the
allegations against Edie Henry are
obviously quite a bit more serious but
the seriousness of them raises questions
in and of itself she says that she was
stripped cuffed and assaulted in a hotel
room now if that happened it's a brutal
violent felony multiple is his rape
kidnapping aggravated assault I mean
we've got probably a dozen violent
felonies here and according to this he
said he's a he's a violent kidnapper and
rapist and should be facing life in
prison if all of this happened exactly
as it said so why is this a civil
complaint in that case rather than a
criminal complaint why did she go to the
police to say that I was kidnapped bound
and raped by a man that's according to
this story this is a this is a shocking
felony that was committed why didn't she
immediately go to the police after
freeing herself and escaping you know I
mean you can argue that in some of these
cases of legitimate harassment and you
know there's always the question of well
why didn't you say something earlier and
sometimes that there could be a valid
reason that nothing was said earlier
maybe you were uncomfortable maybe you
know you you weren't sure if it rose to
the level of harassment or not maybe you
know you were worried about professional
consequences I mean we could see all
that but in with something like this
it's mind-boggling that you wouldn't go
to the police right away with something
like that I mean that is that is so that
is such a horrific crime that you would
have suffered that it's it's hard to
understand why you would
immediately go to the police so it's
it's it's a strange thing and it's not
something that a thinking person can
just take immediately on face value
maybe it happened maybe it's exactly as
it's being described but there are
reasons to take a step back and and
wonder what's what's going on here and
anyway regardless this can't be lumped
in with the claims against Tucker and
Hannity which are just completely and
obviously without merit and we know that
because even if they happened they don't
rise anywhere close to the level of
harassment again she wasn't even a
co-worker of theirs and call me cynical
but I suspect that that's actually what
she might be mad about you know she's
not getting those sweet fox bucks like
she wants so she's finding another way
to go about it that it would just be a
potential theory of the case here in a
theory that to me makes a lot more sense
than what we're getting from this woman
in relation to Tucker and Hannity
especially and that the real point here
is that all of this the avalanche of
attacks all of them gratuitous against
Tucker Carlson specifically is what
happens to people who peek their heads
too far above the crowd who become too
much of a problem to the left because
this is how the left plays the game is a
take-no-prisoners approach win at any
cost they it's not enough to just beat
you they want to destroy you they want
to destroy you and everyone you love and
everyone who knows you that's the way
they handle it and we should always
remember that and act accordingly all
right let's go to five headlines
[Music]
the rioters in Portland are still added
of course let's check in and see how
that's going on
[Applause]
you know you see videos like that and
yet we should remember that yes these
are violent domestic terrorists who
should all be arrested and sent to
prison but also these are scrawny weak
pathetic wimps and that's and that's the
thing that always jumps out at you when
you see these videos there's a reason
why they operate in packs in groups and
that's how they attack people that's how
they do everything because one on one
these are just utterly pathetic and
unimpressive people and that's a big
reason why they're doing what they're
doing it's it's a way of feeling I mean
a lot of these people probably were
bullied in school and have just been
treated as pathetic and unimpressive
because they are their whole lives and
now they're finding a way to finally an
outlet where they can feel strong and
powerful they put on the black costume
in the mask and they go out and smash
stuff but they can't even successfully
smash glass with a with a you know with
a fire extinguisher because you know
probably the guy you're seeing they're
probably bench presses 47 pounds or
something if that so that's it and
that's the balance I always want to
strike when we talk about antifa and the
rioters that on one hand they do
represent a very real threat but I don't
you know I also don't want to make the
mistake of portraying them as if they
individually are tough and scary people
because they are at all but you put a
group of any I mean you put doesn't
matter how weak and and and pitiful you
are as a person if you get together in a
group of a hundred people or more and
you've got weapons and you're setting
fires yeah you're gonna be dangerous
okay let's go to number two here report
from The Daily wire says the wife of
ABC's good morning host George
Stephanopoulos revealed she's perfectly
willing to
teach her teenage daughter's about sex
by watching porn with them Ali Wentworth
whose daughters are 15 and 17 told the
dissenters podcast that porn would be
educational for them because she could
explain that porn is performative rather
than realistic according to Yahoo news
Wentworth said in porn women have been
conditioned to look and act a certain
way they are performing and it's
dangerous to have boys see this as
something women want you can't stop them
so I would watch it with them I would
look at the porn with them that one time
like they're performing and then she
goes on I have an issue with how we are
raising this generation of children
because we grew up without social media
for us our children us as parents are
guinea pigs you know what I mean I don't
know what to say about don't use your
phone use your phone and I start
learning as I went when I would see
other people's daughters and how
sexualized they were on social media and
I became very passionate about the idea
that we went to we want to regulate
social media we need to chart these
waters for our kids so I started doing
these panels on the social media and its
effects and my feeling was this was a
very dangerous thing I see it with other
kids our suicide rate too has doubled I
see the bad effects I think there are
good effects too I mean this I'm just
reading a transcript right now this
doesn't make any sense it sounds like
was she drunk or something when that
that wouldn't make it much better
they'll make it a little bit better if
she was drunk when she did I have no
idea if she was or not but this is
largely and go here I mean we do find
that she's worried about people's
daughters being sexualized she seems to
be worried from what I can decipher a
about the effects of social media and
her way of responding to that is to
watch hardcore pornography with her
daughters including her 15 year old
daughter nothing matters I mean really
it doesn't matter how old the daughter
is that's just creepy and disgusting and
weird to put up mildly so there's George
Stephanopoulos his wife number three
reading again from the daily wire says
st. Louis Circuit attorney Kim Gardner a
Democrat announced on Monday that she's
charging the st. Louis couple defended
their private property using firearms
last month with felony unlawful use of a
weapon the couple also reportedly faces
a
fourth degree misdemeanor assault charge
the st. Louis Dispatch reported markup
attrition McClaskey each are facing a
single felony count of unlawful use of a
weapon exhibiting charging documents say
he pointed an ar-15 rifle at protesters
and she wielded a semi-automatic handgun
placing those protesters in fear of
injury so just to reiterate on this case
because this is obviously an outrageous
miscarriage of justice and and the
governor's R has already said that he
would pardon if there were charges
brought he would pardon these two
American citizens who are only defending
their own property and I'm glad to hear
that but the fact that charges were
pressed at all is as I said outrageous
they're standing on their own property
holding firearms that is their second
Amendment right this is a direct attack
on the Second Amendment and it's not as
though despite what we hear from the
media it's not as though they had no
reason to think that these supposed
peaceful protesters might be violent
this is how dumb the media thinks we are
and this is how dumb a lot of people
actually are that they're you know
they're portraying the McCluskey's as
these gun-toting lunatics and say well
what why would they think that they were
in any risk of me these were peaceful as
if we haven't all been watching the news
for - for two months and seeing cities
across the country buildings being
burned at random people assaulted let's
pretend we haven't seen that know it
well except for all of that there's just
no reason at all to think that for them
to have thought that they were in any
physical danger at all
number four going back to the Portland
riots for a moment here's another
interesting recent phenomenon at these
riots first let's just watch this
footage here
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so what you're seeing there are the moms
the antifoam moms have shown up and they
are forming a human chain a shield to
shield their precious children as their
precious children commit felonies such
as trying to set a federal building on
fire so commit serious serious dangerous
felonies the moms have shown up to help
them now a to embed them in their crimes
so to those of us who had been
theorizing that one of the reasons why
antifa exists is because of horrible
parenting now we have confirmation for
that theory if there was any doubt at
all the the pair the terrible neglectful
awful parents have actually showed up to
advertise but to all but announced oh
yeah yeah we're horrible we'll look at
us look how horrible we are they're on
parade they are parading their awful
parenting for all of us to see so glad
glad to get that confirmation that feels
that feels good at least number five and
now the AP the AP is the latest to come
out and say that the the word black
should be capitalized but not white and
we've seen this more and more recently
but I want you to listen to here's the
AP explaining why there is this
dichotomy where we capitalize one and
not the other says the AP said this is
according to an AP report the AP said
white people in general have much less
shared history and culture and don't
have the experience of being
discriminated against because of skin
color we agree that this is now John
Danis shouts key the AP is
vice-president for standards said in a
memo we agree that white people skin
color plays into systemic inequalities
and justices and we want our journalism
to robustly explore these problems but
capitalizing the term white as is done
by white supremacists risks subtly
conveying legitimacy to such beliefs
okay this is obviously nonsense I mean
even if I were to agree that white
people are never discriminated against
because of their skin color which of
course is not true we talk about
systemic racism okay
the only explicit out in the open
example of actual systemic racism like
it's a policy that we're going to
discriminate against certain races the
only one that nilly example anyone could
come up with is affirmative action and
that's that is discrimination against
white people so but even if I were to
agree with that you know white people
don't have the experience of being
discriminated against what does that
have to do with grammar what does that
do with punctuation so we're you're
gonna capitalisation rather so you you
capitalize the first letter in the word
black because they're discovery against
but not but not white because they're
not what relation is there between those
two things it's a total nonsense but
this is the left-turning
grammar into as and this is not the
first example of it obviously but this
is grammar being politicized this is a
grab even grammar now is an ideological
concern and so even when you're deciding
what letters to capitalize it's you're
not you're not making a determination
based on any grammatical rule you're
making it based on ideological doctrine
and that's what we see once again all
right where to go to our daily
cancellation before we do you know
there's so much going on this year it's
hard to know where even to start and you
know we just you just heard a list of
all the the news stories that's just
that's just a small sample just from
today and then of course you have the
left-wing media constantly pushing their
agenda instead of doing actual reporting
well you can't get the real story you
have to go outside the narrative and get
the facts so if you're just a political
junkie set on getting both sides of the
story whatever it is get a readers pass
today from daily wire.com you'll get
access to exclusive op-eds from your
podcast hopes hosts like yours truly as
well as guest writers and in-depth
analysis from our excellent daily wire
reporters you could go right now and see
my latest piece that I just put up
talking about you know the the school
system basically arguing now that school
that the public school system itself is
in essential and as a homeschool parent
I happen to agree
and I flush out that argument there this
membership tier is already a bargain at
$3 a month so if you join today you get
your first month for 99 cents you also
get access to our mobile app you receive
push notifications for breaking news and
special content as well as you can join
the community of daily wire members who
are actively commenting and discussing
our content with each other that's
mobile ad free access to all of our
daily wire news exclusive op-eds and all
of our podcasts on our mobile app go to
daily wire comm slash subscribe now okay
now for our daily cancellation we're
gonna be cancelling this naked
exhibitionist and her fans and media
maybe you've seen this picture this is
I'm told an iconic picture a
historically significant picture I have
been I have been reliably informed of an
unidentified pervert showing up naked to
the Portland riots and actually as you
can see here spreading her legs for the
officers this is supposed to be a way I
guess of showing the officers showing
them something she she's certainly
showing him something all right
specifically her genitalia is what she's
showing them and of course the media
loves this perhaps not surprisingly
here's the LA Times practically breaking
into poetry when describing this woman
is their article says she emerged as an
apparition from clouds of tear gas as
federal agents fired pepper balls at
angry protesters in the early Saturday
darkness a woman wearing nothing but a
black black face mask at a stocking cap
strode towards a dozen heavily armed
agents a tired and camouflage fatigues
lined up across a downtown Portland
Street the agents dispatched by the
Trump administration over of a tsipras
objections of state and city officials
are part of a force that has fired
projectiles at and detained activists
protesting nightly since the killing of
George Floyd by Minneapolis Police May
25th oh we're still pretending we're
still pretending this has anything to do
with George Floyd whatsoever okay
numerous photos and videos posted on
Twitter show the unidentified woman as
she she halted in the middle of the
street at about 1:45 a.m. she stood
calmly a surreal image of human
vulnerability in the face of an overpass
force that has been criticized
nationally by civil rights advocates the
agents and gas masks and helmets
continued firing pepper balls in a
staccato pop-pop-pop heard on video
aiming low at the asphalt where puffs of
smoke mingled with clouds of gas before
it was over she struck ballet poses and
reclined on the street she also sat on
the asphalt in a yoga like position
facing officers before they left the
woman making her statement Saturday was
altogether uninhibited at one point
standing on one leg and raising her arms
in a arc type motion as she struck
ballet poses a patrol car arrived and a
dozen officers and blue uniforms
replaced the line of agents ok and then
it goes I mean this thing goes on
forever I was I can't even come near
arguing or reading the entire thing ok
but this is all for a chick who showed
the cops her genitals now I want you to
imagine for a moment a different
scenario slightly different ok but but
analogous let's say this was a woman's
March and those were a bunch of women
holding shot your abortion signs instead
of cops instead of male comes largely
and then imagine a naked man comes out
emerges as an apparition from the
darkness as the LA Times would say and
strikes a bunch of naked poses exposing
his whole nude self in all his glory
before these these these women what do
you think any chance that dude is
celebrated would hit think you think
they're gonna be celebrating that no on
the contrary of course he would be
condemned as a sex predator probably
arrested as such and officially charged
he'd be on the sex offender registry
already and his performance would be
seen as further evidence that
masculinity is toxic and dangerous and
women are oppressed and so on and so on
and so and so on this is why we need the
me to movement you see right here oh but
this is different somehow right this is
this is different
how is it different why is it different
nobody can explain now we can explain
but it just is we're supposed to accept
we're supposed to simply accept that
it's different and go along with it
well no we shouldn't accept it and this
is something that when it comes to
especially the double standard mean the
double standard when it was especially
with how women are treated vers men this
the standards that men are held to
versus women I mean the double standards
there are glaring obvious to anyone with
two brain cells but this does become I
think for some conservatives a little
bit complicated because as conservatives
and I actually agree that men and women
are not the same and this is what we've
been saying all along and actually men
and women should not be treated the same
you know we shouldn't in in our daily
lives and in the way we treat each other
we shouldn't just pretend that if you're
dealing with a woman or a man it's
exactly the same there is a difference
and so as conservatives we should we
should recognize that and I've heard
some conservative facts someone on
Twitter today was making this argument
to me that yeah this is a double
standard but there should be a double
say this is what we think as
conservatives so we shouldn't complain
about this
um no no yes I believe that men and
women are not the same and shouldn't be
necessarily treated the same that's what
chivalry is about okay as men we're
gonna you know respond to women a little
bit differently for one of his
Schiller's I believe in that but that
doesn't mean this should go without
saying it doesn't mean that we should
give women the license to be jerks and
perverts and degenerates while
condemning men for the same not not only
that but giving women license and
actually celebrating them for being
jerks perverts and degenerates while
accusing men of being those things even
when they're not so just perfect example
here here's a woman naked spreading her
legs for officers in the middle of the
street okay and and and we're supposed
to celebrate that on the other hand if
you have a man on a subway who's fully
clothed and slightly spreading his legs
a little bit because he's you know it's
just he's a man and so anatomically he's
not able to sit exactly how a woman can
sit because he has other shall we say
concerns yes to take into account here
that is supposed to be gratuitous and
awful and patriarchal and inny or that's
a big problem with that PSA is about it
and and with signs on the subway telling
men not to man spread okay that's an
example of treating men and women
differently in a way that is not good
and that we should not support as
conservatives or as any event okay what
your political leaning is we should not
support that so there's a difference
between advocating for chivalry and for
recognizing the inherent differences
between the sexes you know you could do
that that doesn't mean giving license to
women to act in exactly the kinds of
ways they're constantly accusing men of
acting and complaining about men acting
that way so no and there's of course
nothing chivalrous about seeing that
display and celebrating it again should
shouldn't need to be explained I don't
think I should need to spell this out
but I think I do these double standards
no we can't accept them we shouldn't
accept them we shouldn't go along with
them I think
too many people are willing to and we
should all right so cancel we're
cancelling who we cancelling we're
cancelling the woman we're cancelling
you know the media everybody everyone
involved is canceled on this one and
we're gonna wrap it up there but before
I do you know it's sort of to mention
Ben Shapiro's book how to destroy
American three easy steps goes on sale
Tuesday July 21st which last I checked
is today so it goes on sale today at 6
p.m. Eastern 3 p.m. Pacific Ben's gonna
be doing a virtual live signing event
with your purchase of a signed copy you
can write in questions which may be read
on air and you as you send the books
he'll read those so go to daily wire.com
slash abend right now now's your chance
still if you still have a little bit of
time to pre-order the book so I would
encourage you to do that and then be a
part of Ben's live signing on Tuesday
July 21st which is today so that'll be
exciting and it's a great book as well I
have it on my shelf and I've been I've
been reading it the last couple of days
we'll wrap it up there thanks for
watching everybody thanks for listening
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 doctor foul she throws out
the first pitch for the Washington
Nationals Kanye West gets freedom and
naked Athena streaks for the cops check
it out on the Michael no show
[Music]
you